now
i'm at the point where
the work is gonna
show i feel like i put a lot of hours in
i sacrificed a lot of stuff so
if you don't believe in yourself then
who really will
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up samia wheelchair class of 2023
from the university of north carolina
commit all right
growing up i wasn't really i wasn't
really a basketball player
i started really taking basketball
serious at around like
seven eight years old
just being around
watching everybody play going high
school games
me and my pops would travel me my past
my brother my mom
so that just helped
like grow my love for it and then over
the years watching players my love is
growing by the day
sometimes i catch myself watching
highlight reels of myself
[Applause]
like that's what i used to do and i used
to go on youtube and just
watch players
so now it's just like it's kind of crazy
to me
that i know somewhere out there that
somebody's actually searching my name up
on google and
watching me play
[Applause]
as a pooper you really motivate people
to keep going
so knowing that i can actually help
somebody
somebody out there get through whatever
they're going through
[Applause]
putting on the jersey for roseau means a
lot
knowing that the the recent history in
the last 10 years
that roselle's won three tocs
that means a lot
not everybody is blessed with an
opportunity
[Applause]
freshman year i was the i was the little
brother to everybody yeah really i was
my older brother was on the team with me
i always play with a trip on my shoulder
because some people like
just toss me to the side a little bit
and i don't really like that
and also
i feed off like like my older brother
but he didn't really get to get the
shine that i feel like he deserved
so
that just adds to the chip on my
shoulder i feel like i'm doing it for
him too
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today was a good game against a good
national team with a couple of really
good players didn't have our a game
still found a way to win by doing the
things that we needed to do all right
congratulations good win bring it up
but i want for my future involving
basketball i wanted to take me to the
nba not only just to be a player and
just get drafted i want to be a
superstar
and be a role model for the younger kids
i love basketball
i love basketball and my love is just
going to grow as the years going